so blueprints for 3d printed plastic
guns
are banned from the internet for now
you'll remember the controversy last
year when the trump administration
allowed a texas company to make the
digital blueprints available
online but a federal judge ruled
yesterday that this agreement broke
federal law now these guns can fire
bullets
like real guns but they may not be
picked up by metal detectors and are
very very hard to trace
now tony back in august you had an
interview with cody wilson the founder
of the company in question
and he's told you something that raised
a lot of eyebrows broke a lot of news
i'm going to play a bit of that
when somebody downloads a gun from your
website with your blueprints
and kill somebody with it how are you
going to feel personally
i don't believe that i if i allow you to
download an ar-15
the full plans on ar-15 i don't believe
that i provided you anything other than
the general knowledge of what an ar-15
is
so cody's being a little bit coy there i
mean
what what his mission is is to make
everybody not only a gun owner but a
potential gun manufacturer and if you
give the public the ability to make a
gun
then no government agency can restrict
that you were essentially your own
manufacturer
yeah well proponents of this say
obviously
it's a first amendment a second
amendment protection issue
and there are some who say look this is
dangerous because the metal detectors
anybody can print one cody has a
tombstone in his office with gun control
written on it he's trying to do away
with any regulation of firearms at all
full stop period
wow okay